>>Male Presenter: I think most people here
know Larry Lessig.
You should know him either from his work at
Stanford or Harvard, Creative Commons, helped
out the Electronic Frontier Foundation, the
Sunlight Foundation.
There's a whole bunch of places you should
know him from.
But really the reason why we wanna pay attention
to what he has to say is because he's been
right on so many issues, whether arguing in
front of the Supreme Court, talking about
things like copyright extension, or--if people
noticed a few years ago--he started to move
away from copyright and started to talk about
broader issues.
Specifically, the influence or potential corruption
of money in politics and a lot of institutions
that are important in the United States.
So, I think it's important that we make sure
that Larry not be a Cassandra.
You know, the prophet who could hear the future,
but no one would ever believe her.
And so, I think it's important for us to listen
to what he's got to say today.
Read through the book.
It's really good.
Don't forget to badge in.
But also, after the talk, please take a little
while and ask, "How can we try to make sure
that he's not a Cassandra--that we do take
these issues seriously?"
Because, I think, the influence of money in
politics and in our institutions is probably
the most important issue facing us today in
the United States.
So with that, thanks very much to Larry Lessig.
[applause]
>>Lawrence Lessig: Thank, Matt.
And it's great to be back.
I have one sacred text.
"There are a thousand hacking at the branches
of evil."
Henry David Thoreau, 1846, on Walden.
There are a thousand hacking at the branches
of evil to one who is striking at the roots.
Imagine a letter written by a young woman.
"There were two clocks regulating our life--the
one on the wall and the one in the bottle.
We built our life around those clocks.
He slept late so mornings were bliss.
“We could play and laugh without fear.
But at some point, he would awake.
And soon after he woke, the bottle was opened.
And then the older the day grew, the more
terrifying my life became.
He was happy at first--just before dinner,
the most happy.
“That's the only time I spoke to him, a
moment to pretend I had a father who had a
feeling of love.
He'd smile.
He'd laugh.
But then, he'd grow irritated.
And by the end of dinner, he was angry and
if we weren't gone--usually just hiding in
our room by nine--he'd be violent.
He hit me more than once.
“Once he tried to do something worse than
hitting me and then I left and I never went
back.
We struggled to do many things in that house
to keep food in the house, to keep the winter
out of the house, to keep the house.
But the one thing we never even spoke about
was getting him to stop.
“I don't know why.
The bottle was just part of our life.
We learned to live with it.
Anything more just seemed impossible."
Now, the thing about us--we humans--is that
we adapt, we adjust, we learn to live with
it until we can't.
And then a certain fever breaks out and if
we're lucky, we have this Thoreauvian moment--a
recognition that we have to stop hacking at
the branches and start striking at the roots,
the recognition that we have to become this
sense of a root striker.
OK.
So, here's the argument here.
I think that there's this feeling among too
many of us Americans that we just might not
make it.
Not that the end is near or that doom is around
the corner, but that a distinctly American
feeling of inevitability of greatness, culturally,
economically, politically, is gone--that we
have become Britain or Rome or Greece.
A generation ago, Ronald Reagan rallied the
nation to deny a similar charge: Jimmy Carter's
fear that we had fallen into a state of malaise.
And I confess.
I was one of those so rallied and I still
believe Reagan was right today.
But the feeling I'm talking about today is
different.
Not that we, as a people, have lost anything
of our potential, but that we, as a Republic,
have.
That our capacity for governing, the one thing
that we were once most proud of, this our
Republic, is the one thing that we have all
learned to ignore.
Government is an embarrassment.
And it has lost the capacity to make the most
essential decisions and slowly it dawns upon
us that a ship that cannot be steered is a
ship that will sink.
This is not a Democratic or Republican point
alone.
This is a genuinely multi-partisan frustration.
The sense that the government doesn't work
is signaled by many different policy areas
on the left and the right, which systematically
get blocked.
And when confronted with this systematic block,
my suggestion is we need to exercise this
Thoreauvian insight.
So, my objective this afternoon is to do a
little bit of brainwashing.
[laughter]
To get you to the place that you see the roots
that I want you to see.
I'm gonna do that with three some examples.
One of them is familiar.
Indeed, I told a similar story here the last
time I was here--the story around copyright.
On October 27th, 1998, I became a copyright
activist the day President Clinton signed
into law a statute in honor of this great
American, the Sonny Bono Copyright Term Extension
Act--a statute which extended the term of
existing copyrights by 20 years.
Now, the question Congress was supposed to
be asking when it passed that statute was,
"Would it advance the public good to extend
the term of an existing copyright by 20 years?"
Copyrights are designed to create incentives,
but we know about this universe.
Put aside Star Trek for a moment.
What we know about this universe is that its
incentives are prospective.
So, not even the United States Congress can
get George Gershwin to produce anything more.
[laughter]
So when you ask the question, "Does it make
sense to advance the public good to extend
the term of existing copyright?" it's a pretty
easy answer.
Indeed, when we challenged this statute in
the Supreme Court and a bunch of economists
wanted to sign a brief saying it did not advance
the public good, this liberal, left-wing--.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Wait.
This is Milton Friedman--right-wing, Nobel
Prize winning economist, agreed to sign the
brief but only if the word "no brainer" was
in the brief somewhere.
[laughter]
So obvious was it that you could not extend
the public good by extending the term of existing
copyrights.
But apparently there were no brains in this
place when Congress unanimously extended the
term of these existing copyrights.
What there was, was more than six million
dollars in contributions from Disney and related
corporations seeking the extension of their
valuable copyrights--the public be damned.
Here's another example.
Wall Street Journal, at the end of last year,
was puzzled about the explosion of temporary
tax provisions in our tax code.
These temporary tax provisions expire after
a limited period of time.
And that leads to this extender mania, as
lobbyists and Congress race around to try
to extend the particular tax provision for
another period of time.
And the Journal wondered what explains the
explosion and change in the number of these
extensions.
Well, it turns out the first of these temporary
provisions was given to us by Reagan in 1981.
Congress passed the Research and Development
Tax Credit.
But because the Democrats were skeptical about
whether it would work, they made the tax credit
temporary.
They said they would test it after a number
of years.
And if it turned out it worked, they would
make it permanent.
If it didn't work, they would repeal it.
So, after a couple years, the economists asked
the question, "Did it work?"
The answer is yes.
Left and right economists all agreed that
it did work.
It was a great tax idea.
It spurred a kind of investment that otherwise
would not have been spurred.
And so, it made sense absolutely to make this
part of the tax code.
Here's the puzzle.
It is still temporary to this day.
Why?
Well, as Rebecca Kysar describes in this piece
in the Georgia Law Review, "The principle
recipients of the research credit are large
US manufacturing corporations.
These business entities are more than willing
to invest in lobbying activities and campaign
donations to ensure the continuance of this
large tax savings."
The Institute for Policy Innovation put it
a little bit more sharply.
"This cycle has repeated for years.
Congress allows the credit to lapse until
another short extension is given.
Proceeded, of course, by a series of fundraisers
and speeches about the importance of nurturing
innovation.
Congress essentially uses the cycle to raise
money for re-election, promising industry
more predictability the next time around."
Now this dynamic is central to how Washington
works.
We architect tax policy in part, at least,
not just to raise money for our treasury,
but to make it easier to raise money for our
Congressmen's campaigns.
And not just tax policy.
When Al Gore was Vice President, he had an
idea to simplify the regulation governing
infrastructure that internet would come across.
Right now, we have two titles in the Communications
Act--Title Two and Title Six.
Title Two governs telephones.
Title Six governs cable.
Those are two radically different regulatory
structures.
Gore's idea was to put them together in a
Title Seven and fundamentally deregulate them--much
less than even network neutrality regulation
would require.
His team took the idea to Capitol Hill and
the chief policy person described--the reaction,
he said the reaction was quote, "Hell no.
If we deregulate these guys, how are we going
to raise money from them?"
And you get this kind of sinking, terrifying
feeling here, right?
Recognizing that we tax in part to make it
easy to raise campaign funds.
We regulate, in part, to make it easier to
raise campaign funds.
Campaign funds driving critical areas of fiscal
policy unrelated to the merits of the underlying
fiscal policy.
Here's the third example.
Think about Wall Street.
We've of course seen this collapse on Wall
Street, which triggered a collapse in the
economy.
What explains that collapse?
Well, as Simon Johnson and James Kwak describe
in their book, "13 Bankers," part of the explanation
is this perverse mix of too little government
and too much government.
Too little government in the form of deregulation.
In the 1990s, we saw an explosion of financial
innovations, derivatives.
But these innovations were essentially invisible
to the market because a series of regulatory
changes in the 1990s made derivatives, unlike
other financial assets, not subject to the
standard requirements that have existed since
the new deal that they be traded on public
exchanges, transparently with anti-fraud obligations
tied to every transaction.
So, my colleague, Frank Partnoy, calculated
that in 1980, 98 percent of assets traded
in our economy were traded under these standard
new deal, trade-based rules.
But by 2008, 90 percent of the assets traded
in our economy were exempted from these exchange-based
rules, could be traded without transparency,
could be traded without anybody knowing what
the prices would be for.
It could be traded without any anti-fraud
requirements being tied to them, producing
this shadow banking market, which encouraged--because
of the uncertainty it spewed everywhere--the
bubble which eventually burst and brought
the economy down.
But that alone, Kwak and Johnson say, wasn't
enough.
In addition, we had too much government.
Throughout the 1990s, there was a beacon,
a constant signal from the government that
there was, in effect, a government guarantee
that when this bubble burst there would be
a bailout on the other side producing what
is the dumbest form of socialism ever invented
by man--socialized risk and privatized benefit.
We suffer the downside.
They get the upside.
Now I know you guys are not lawyers.
This is a technical legal term, but this is
an insanely stupid way--
[laughter]
to set up a financial system.
And all that stupidity is just before 2008.
Even worse is after 2008, where we add insult
to injury in the way that Congress increasingly
functions.
Because after 2008, after the worst crisis
since the Depression, after all who are not
involved in that crisis had concluded that
one of the principle causes to that crisis
was the architecture of deregulation that
Wall Street had purchased until 2008, after
the dean of deregulation, the Ayn Rand-ian,
Alan Greenspan, Head of the Fed, confessed
in testimony to Congress that he was quote
"mistaken" about whether the banks would act
in the public interest as opposed to their
private interest.
After all of that, Wall Street was still powerful
enough to blackmail the Democrats and Republicans
both to give them an essential "get out of
jail free" card and to keep the core flaw
of our architecture of regulation the same.
If the banks were too big to fail before 2008,
the banks are only too bigger to fail after
2008, leading many Independents of Wall Street
to include that our risk of a collapse is
greater today than it was before the collapse
in 2008.
Again, why?
What would explain this stupidity in the architecture
of regulation?
Well, lots of possible reasons, but here's
the one thing we know.
The fastest growing sector in campaign contributions
since 1991, and the largest chunk of contributions
in the 2010 election, come from the finance
and insurance industries.
OK.
Here's one final example.
I'm sure many of you, when you saw these images,
had a question in the back of your head.
How was it that it's possible to launch such
an experimental drilling platform, as the
Deepwater Horizon, without extensive environmental
impact and risk studies?
All right.
In my part of the country, we've just spent
nine years and ten thousand pages of environmental
impact studies to permit the construction
of this green energy technology.
So, exactly how much was required before they
were able to build the experimental deep water
drilling platform, which was the Deepwater
Horizon?
The answer is 17 pages before they were exempted
from any further need for review, leading
Congress to be shocked of course.
[plays video clip]
>>Male #1: I am shocked--shocked--to find
that gambling is going on in here.
>>Male #2: Your winnings, sir.
>>Male #1: Thank you very much.
Everybody out in front.
[laughter]
[end video clip]
>>Lawrence Lessig: And of course, it was Congress
that had required these fast track approval
processes, leading again to the question,
"What would ever convince them that fast track
approval on experimental drilling wells made
sense?"
Lots of possible answers to that question.
The one thing we know is endless campaign
cash driving to this conclusion.
Now, here's the point.
No respectable Liberal or Libertarian or Conservative
could defend these cases.
Each of them is an abomination from each of
those three political philosophy perspectives.
So, how is it they become policy in the United
States?
Now, it turns out political sciences are uncertain.
They say it's a little bit complex.
But here's the thing.
You believe you know.
I just had to point to point to the money.
And you believe you now know the root cause
to this stupidity.
And that's the core of my claim.
Number one, it is because of cases like this,
and I could go on for hours, I promise--millions
of cases like this--that Americans believe
money buys results in Congress.
Seventy-five percent of Americans in a poll
that we conducted for my book conclude money
buys results in Congress.
You think, "What were the 25 percent thinking?"
I don't know.
[laughter]
But a little bit more Democrats than Republicans.
But I guarantee you when the Republicans were
not in control, it was just as many Republicans
as Democrats.
So, whether it's two-thirds or three-fourths,
here's the thing we Americans all agree about.
Money buys results in Congress.
Leading to number two.
A belief in money buying results erodes trust
in the institution.
So, last year Gallup concluded that eleven
percent of Americans have confidence in Congress.
Gallup's number this year is a little more
optimistic.
They say 12 percent.
[laughter]
But I just read today in the New York Times--New
York Times CBS poll says that nine percent
of Americans have confidence in Congress.
To keep this in some context, right, it is
certainly the case that there were more people
who believed in the British crown at the time
of the Revolution than believe in our Congress
today.
[laughter]
And at what point does an institution have
to declare political bankruptcy?
At what point has it just lost the credibility
with the people?
What, nine percent isn't enough?
Five percent?
What is the number when we have to say there
is no more confidence in this government?
And that leads to number three.
Low trust erodes participation in the system.
Rock the Vote, the organization that registered
and turned out to vote the largest number
of young people who ever voted in the history
of this nation, and arguably delivered the
election to Barack Obama, in 2010, found a
large number of their voters were not gonna
turn out and vote.
So, they polled them.
Why?
Number one answer to that poll by far--two
to one over the second highest--was "no matter
who wins, corporate interest will still have
too much power and prevent real change."
And it's not just kids who think this.
The vast majority of people, who could have
voted, didn't vote and didn't vote in part
because of this belief precisely.
Now here, I'm gonna shift into professor mode.
Here's my blackboard.
It wasn't supposed to be this way.
That wasn't the intent.
Framers of our Constitution gave us, as Conservatives
like to remind us, a Republic.
But what they meant by a Republic was a quote
"representative democracy."
And what they meant by a representative democracy
as Federalist 52 puts it was, "a government
that would have a branch quote 'dependent
upon the people alone.'"
OK?
So, here's the model of government.
We have the people.
We have the government.
I do my own slides, so it's cool the way that
bounces, right?
[laughter]
The people, the government, marionette relationship
between the two.
Here's the problem.
Congress has evolved a different dependence.
It's not just the people and the government.
Increasingly, it's the funders and the people
and the government.
In a world where members spend between 30
and 70 percent of their time raising money
to get back to Congress, or to get their Party
back into power--they can't help, like each
of you couldn't help--developing a sixth sense,
a constant awareness about how what they do
might affect their ability to raise money.
In the words of the "X-Files," they become
shape-shifters, constantly adjusting their
positions.
Not on issues one to ten, but issue eleven
to five hundred in light of what they know
will raise money.
Leslie Byrne describes it when she came to
Congress.
She's a Democrat from Virginia.
She was told by a colleague quote, "Always
lean to the green."
And then to clarify, she went on, "he was
not an environmentalist."
[laughter]
Now, the point is this a dependence, too.
But it's a different and conflicting dependence
from a dependence upon the people alone because--surprise,
surprise--the funders are not the people.
Indeed, candidates pay attention in campaigns
most to those who max out in the campaign.
So, what percentage of Americans maxed out
in 2010 in congressional elections in either
of the two cycles?
The answer is point zero five percent of Americans.
So, the Occupy Wall Street people are so proud
of their slogan, "We are the 99 percent."
Bad marketing.
They are the 99 point nine five percent,--
[laughter]
who don't get listened to because they are
not in the point zero five percent of people
who are directly tied into the influence that
is our government.
Now, this is--Supreme Court doesn't recognize
this yet, but you should.
This is corruption.
It's not the corruption of brown paper bags
secreting cash among members of Congress.
Up through the middle of the 20th Century,
members of Congress had safes in their office
for cash.
You think to yourselves, "I didn't know that
they paid Congressmen in cash."
They didn't.
[laughter]
They just discovered that there would be cash
on their desk and they needed a place to keep
it.
[laughter] So, that was the way things were.
But that's not the problem today.
Our Congress, in that sense, is the cleanest
Congress in the history of Congress.
It's not filled with Rod Blagojeviches.
It's not filled with people who are violating
any law.
None of the corruption I'm talking about is
illegal.
It's all legal, in plain sight.
But it is corruption because it's relative
to the baseline the framers gave us of the
dependence upon the people alone.
We have corrupted that dependence.
It is a dependence corruption because the
wrong dependence has been allowed to step
into the middle of this system.
So then, what does the corruption do?
How does it affect the results?
Well, you can think about its effect in substance.
But it turns out, interestingly, bizarrely,
but interestingly, this controversy about
whether it affects the results.
There's some people who believe it doesn't
affect the results.
Indeed, the former Chairman of the Federal
Election Commission, Bradley Smith--I quote
in his book, said this.
"The evidence is pretty overwhelming that
money does not play much of a role in what
goes on in terms of legislative voting patterns
and legislative behavior.
The consensus about that among people who
have studied it, is roughly the same as the
consensus among scientists that global warming
is taking place."
[laughter]
Now, to be clear, Bradley Smith is not a global
warming denier.
He is a corruption denier.
And he said this--we were on in interview
on the radio.
I just couldn't believe it.
I had to tweet it.
But then I got in a lot of trouble for this
hash tag.
[laughter]
But of course, that hash tag just means Bradley
Smith--
[laughter]
just talking about--.
OK.
So, do we have evidence that the results are
a function of the money?
Well, there's lots of recent studies that
are beginning to make this absolutely compelling.
One of my favorites is this piece by Clayton
Peoples that looks at seven thousand votes
over a period of 1991 to 2006.
It concludes, can show a statistically significant
contributor influence in at least seven of
the eight Houses.
The one House you couldn't show it was the
House that passed the McCain-Feingold Campaign
Reform Act.
So they were thinking good in that one term,
but not any other period.
But I think more interesting is this piece
by Martin Gilens at Princeton.
Gilens took about 17 hundred public opinion
surveys about attitudes about how policy should
change.
And he narrowed that down to about 887, where
the attitudes of the top ten percent were
different from the attitudes of the bottom
90 percent.
And he asked the question, "When the top ten
percent think we should go left, and the bottom
90 percent think we should go right"-- I don't
mean that left and right politically.
I just mean go one direction and the other
wanna go the other direction.
"--which way do we go?"
And what he found was "when Americans with
different income levels differ in their policy
preferences, actual policy outcomes strongly
reflect the preferences of the most affluent,
but bare virtually no relationship to the
preferences of the poor or middle income Americans."
There is a vast discrepancy between what our
Congress does if it in fact were following
the people alone, and what our Congress does
given that it's following the thing I'm taking
for as the proxy for the funders.
OK.
That's substance.
But here, you can also just more easily identify
agenda because remember, Brad Smith also said
it doesn't affect legislative behavior.
And here, there is no basis for suggesting
Here's just one example.
If I asked you, "What was the number one issue
Congress spent its time on in the first four
months of this year?"
It's felt like many years this year, but just
the first four months.
We're in the middle of two wars, huge unemployment
problems, huge budget deficit problems.
Still have a bunch of questions around health
care and still have a bunch of questions around
global warming that have not even begun to
be addressed.
What was the issue they spent most of their
time dealing with?
The answer is the bank swipe fee controversy.
Now, what's the bank swipe fee controversy?
Well, the bank swipe fee controversy is whether
banks, when you used your debit card, get
to charge more, or retailers when you use
your debit card get to be charged less for
the use of debit cards.
That is the critical national issue that dominated
the Congressional agenda for the first four
months.
And you think, "Well, why would that ever
be?
Why would swipe fees be the center of what
they care about?"
How many members of Congress got elected going
down there saying, "The thing I'm going for
is to deal with that swipe fee controversy."
Right?
Well, the answer is one Senator described
it like this.
"The fights down here can be put into two
or three categories: The big greedy bastards
against the big greedy bastards; the big greedy
bastards against the little greedy bastards;
and some cases even the other little greedy
bastards against the other little greedy bastards."
[laughter]
So we have this kind of controversy.
And here's the money line, so to speak.
I don't even think the authors, Zach Carter
and Ryan Grimm, saw the significance of this,
but this is the real money line in the piece.
They say, "The clock never ticks down to zero
in Washington: one year's law is the next
year's repeal target.
Politicians, showered with cash from card
companies and giant retailers alike, have
been moving back and forth between camps,
paid handsomely for their shifting allegiances."
So, it's not just tax policy that gets architected
to raise money for members of Congress.
It's not just regulation that gets architected
to make it easy to raise money for members
of Congress.
It's the very agenda of what Congress addresses
that gets set in a way to make it easier for
members to raise money.
So why don't we address unemployment?
Turns out unemployment doesn't pay so well
[laughter] for Congressmen raising money for
their campaigns.
Now, my view is we critically need a way to
change this.
And we change this by fixing the dependence.
If the problem here is that the funders are
not the people, a solution is to make the
funders the people, to give them a way--.
I know that looks like one word.
I mean two words, here.
I don't mean give Congress away.
I know a lot of people would like to do that.
I mean, give Congress a way to fund their
campaigns without Faust, without selling their
souls, and thereby without alienating America.
And the one way, and I increasing think the
only way to do this, is to commit to a system
of publicly funding public elections.
Now, a particular brand of public funding
is what I want to pedal here.
I want a public funding that changes from
large-dollar funded campaigns to small-dollar
funded campaigns.
And there are lots of examples of this around
the country.
Three states in particular, Arizona, Maine,
and Connecticut, have systems where candidates
opt into a regime where they take small dollar
contributions only and the regime effectively
amplifies those contributions, so that they
can successfully wage a campaign having never
taken a large dollar contribution from anybody.
There are many ways to do that.
I describe one in my book that's a little
different from what Maine and Connecticut
have done.
And I can talk about that in questions, but
the point I want you to recognize, the critical
point about this way of funding elections,
is if we had an election where the majority
of Congress--the vast majority of Congress--took
small dollar contributions only, then we all
could believe, as we all want to believe,
[laughter] that when Congress did something
stupid it was either because there were too
many Democrats or because there were too many
Republicans, or because they just didn't understand
what they were doing.
But not because of the money.
The essential element of mistrust and cynicism
in the system would've been removed by an
alternative funding system that gave us no
reason to doubt the integrity or credibility
of what that system was doing.
Now, this is a way, I believe, to create a
reassertion of the dominance of the people
and the dependence the framers intended and
to restore the institution of Congress to
at least be a little bit more popular than
King George at the founding.
[laughter]
OK.
Now that's the argument.
Here's the hard question.
How do you get there?
I don't think it's hard to describe the problem.
We all believe we believed in the problem
before I even said anything about it.
And it's not even hard, I think, to describe
a solution.
I'm happy to tell you more about mine, but
I think the solution is pretty clear.
What is hard--maybe what's impossibly hard--is
to imagine the political movement that brings
about the solution.
And the reason for that is an insight given
to me by Congressman Jim Cooper, Democrat
from Tennessee, who has been in Congress for
as long all but about 20 other members of
Congress.
And Cooper said this.
He told me "the problem with Capitol Hill
is it has become a quote 'Farm league for
K Street.'"
K Street, the home of lobbyists.
A farm league for K Street, meaning members
and staffers and bureaucrats have this increasingly
common business model in the back of their
head.
The business model is focused on their life
after government, their life as lobbyists.
Public Citizen calculated between 1998 and
2004, 50 percent of Senators left to become
lobbyists.
Forty-two percent of the members of the House.
Those numbers have only gone up.
And so, in a world where everyone depends
upon the existing system surviving, because
that's the only way they have a lucrative
after-government future, how to we begin to
imagine that institution and those people--the
lobbyists, the members of Congress, the staffers,
the bureaucrats--ever organizing to change
that deeply corrupt system?
Well, in my book, I consider four ideas.
One of them is the ordinary idea--the idea
of passing a statute.
That idea is impossible.
I looked it up on Google.
It is impossible.
[laughter]
It's technically impossible.
It's impossible because there is no way they
will ever radically change the system that
both got them there and will carry them out
in very well-paid lobbyist’s jobs.
So that leads me to three insane solutions
that are only improbable, not quite impossible.
And the third of these, the one that I ultimately
think will be the most important, is this
suggestion of a convention.
So, the framers of our Constitution in Article
Five created the standard way by which the
Constitution gets amended.
That is, Congress proposes an amendment and
three-fourths of the states ratify it.
But then at the convention, somebody said,
"Well, what if Congress is the problem?
What do we do then?"
And so, they set up an alternative path.
The alternative path is that states can call
on Congress to call a convention.
The convention then proposes the amendments
and those amendments have to pass by three-fourths
of the states.
So either way, 38 states have to ratify an
amendment, but the sources of those amendments
are different.
One is inside.
One is outside.
Now, all three of these insane ideas are really
just ways around what is, I think, the cancer
that is DC right now.
And it's recognition that the ordinary means
of politics are just not feasible for this
kind of problem.
In this--you can think of--extraordinary times,
what's gonna be required here is that we do
something that we have not done in a very
long time--to build a politics that looks
different from this.
A politics that is not--to borrow from my
older work-- a 'read-only' politics--where
people sit there and passively consume what's
fed to them in broadcast form.
But instead, read/write politics where people
become more active and engaged and reclaim
this from the politicians.
Now, here's the hard part.
I don't actually know whether it's possible
for us to do it.
We don't have any good evidence that we, as
a people, have the capacity to actually take
back power from the professional politicians
and reorder it.
No good example in our recent past.
Lots of good reason to believe people are
too disengaged to be able to do it.
I do think we know, however, how that process
gets started.
And it begins with, first, clarity.
The clarity of Thoreau.
The clarity of a root striker.
So it might not be surprising that the coolest
website of the Occupy movement is the Occupy
Seattle movement.
But if you go to their demands page, you're
met with this list of literally hundreds of
demands, which they are now trying to decide
which are the most important of their demands.
Everything from protect the environment to--my
favorite--end the industrial prison complex.
OK.
Which is significant there and also here,
but that's the scope.
All right.
Now, I think all of these demands are important.
It would be great to get Congress or the states
to address any of these demands.
But the point is if you come forward with
a list of a hundred demands, you come forward
with noise.
And nobody hears anything because they can't
hear everything you're trying to say.
Instead, this movement needs to find a way
to clarify and focus.
It needs to celebrate its diversity, recognize
there are leftists in that movement.
They shouldn't deny the fact they're leftists.
There are people on the right in the Tea Party
movement.
They shouldn't deny they're from the right.
They should all stick to their principle,
but they've got to seek a common ground.
Not compromise, but a common ground so that
they actually do speak for the 99 percent,
not just the 21 percent of people who identify
as liberals or the 30 percent of people that
identify as supporters of the Tea Party.
I think there's an exercise we all should
go through.
We should be forced to come into a room and
say, "We on the left, believe this.
We on the right, believe this."
But then ask the critical question, whether
there's a set of beliefs that we all share,
that could be the foundation for some important
reform.
And my view is that if we could focus people's
attention on the wide range of issues that
they're frustrated about and get them to connect
the dots--so whether it's on the left, health
care reform, or on the right, government bailouts.
On the left, global warming or on the right,
complex taxes.
On the left, financial reform and on the right,
financial reform.
Whatever the issue is, if we could focus them,
they would see this root cause.
And the root cause is this picture.
A democracy that is distracted by a dependence
that was never intended.
And the practice of the root striker has got
to be to find a way to get, we the people,
to see this root.
So, that's number one--clarity.
Number two is a kind of boldness.
Now, in the book, I make a little bit of fun
of a guy you're familiar with.
[laughter]
So, Eric Schmidt came to a talk at the American
Academy in Berlin.
And it was the first time I'd ever met him,
first time I'd ever heard him talk.
And I was amazed.
It was the first time I'd ever heard anybody
lay out the Google vision.
And I was astonished.
I mean, I was astonished by him.
He was extraordinary, but I was astonished
by the Google vision.
This is a place.
You saw these really big ideas about how they
were gonna, you guys, were gonna remake the
whole world.
The whole world.
And I was more excited about the work going
on here than I had even been in my whole life.
I felt like this was amazing.
So then I thought, "OK.
Wow.
This is a company of big ideas."
And I said, "Eric, so there's a whole bunch
of public policy issues where the world is
against you guys.
And I think you guys are right."
So, immigration, anti-trust, copyrights, network
neutrality.
You guys are on the right side of all of those
issues and the rest of the world is on the
wrong side."
And the reason the rest of the world is on
the wrong side is exactly the corruption that
I've been talking about today.
So, what are you gonna do about it?
Are you gonna sit around and swipe away these
bad policies like flies at a picnic?
Or are you gonna solve it in the way Google
addresses a problem and radically remakes
the world to solve it?
And for the first time in that evening, a
tiny idea was expressed.
And it was expressed by Eric Schmidt.
Because he didn't have any big idea to think
about solving this, the most fundamental problem.
I agree with Matt that we, as a Republic face--any
idea like, "Oh, we're gonna get the Google
PAC to be more aggressive in teaching people
what our views about policies were.
Nothing to change the core root of the problem.
Just playing the system with all sorts of
resources allied against you.
What we need here is a Google-level idea.
What we need is the kind of big idea that
you deploy in every other sphere of social
life that might get this democracy to the
place that could address this problem that
I guarantee you 95 percent of experts say
is impossible for the world to solve, for
us to solve.
Impossible.
But that's the sort of problem you guys take
all the time.
That's what you do.
That's your job--the impossible problem.
And we need that.
And we need that from people like you.
Now, number three, we need courage.
And this is also related to the company, but
I won't pick on the company anymore.
Instead, I'll talk about my friend, Arnold
Hiatt.
So, he's a humble guy.
This is the biggest I could find of him on
the net.
[laughter]
[Lawrence Lessig coughs]
Arnie was the president of Stride Rite.
They make great shoes, like Keds.
He's also a loyal Democrat.
In 1996, he was the second largest contributor
to the Democratic Party.
So, in 1997, Bill Clinton invited him and
30 other large contributors to a dinner at
the Mayflower Hotel to tell him, the President,
what he should do for the remaining part of
his term.
So, it's this dinner of these fat cats at
the Mayflower Hotel to help guide policy in
America.
And each of them got to stand up and address
the President.
We didn't have any pictures.
Arnie was the last one to speak.
I kind of envision it like this.
He stood up and he looked the President straight
in the eye and he said, "Mr. President, I
know you're an admirer of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt.
So I want you to put yourself in Roosevelt's
shoes in 1940, when he reluctantly came to
recognize that he needed to convince a reluctant
nation to wage a war to save democracy."
'Cause he said, "You, too, Mr. President.
You, too, need to convince a reluctant nation
to wage a war to save democracy.
Not a war against fascists, but in a certain
sense, a war against us fat cats."
A war against people who believe, merely because
they are rich, they are entitled to guide
government policy.
People who believe merely because they've
been successful in the marketplace, they're
entitled to have dinner with the President.
People who have convinced the American public
that this republic does not work.
Now, put yourself in Hiatt's shoes.
Imagine yourself in that room with 30 other
fat cats and the President, basically saying
to each of those fat cats and the President,
"This is illegitimate what's happening here."
There was silence after he said what he said.
[laughter]
The only published account of the evening
says that Clinton's response effectively slashed
Hiatt to pieces, humiliating him in front
of the group.
I think 14 years later, we need to recognize
that it was Arnold Hiatt who was right.
We do need to convince a reluctant nation
to wage a war to save democracy.
But where Arnold Hiatt was wrong was in his
belief that politicians would wage that war.
It's not gonna be politicians.
It's gonna be citizens.
It's going to be us.
It's going to be root strikers.
And I pray it's going to be you.
It is our job that requires our courage.
It is our republic.
It is ours, not theirs.
They took it away, but we let them.
Here's one more story before I stop.
So, many of you might remember--actually,
many of you weren't born, but OK.
Many of you might remember this event, 1989.
The Exxon Valdez crashed into Prince William
Sound, ran aground, eleven million gallons
of oil was spilled into the Sound.
This is the recording of Captain Joseph Hazelwood
when he called in the accident.
[plays sound clip]
[static]
>>Captain Joseph Hazelwood: Yeah.
Ah, it’s VALDEZ back.
Ah, we’ve— ah, should be on your radar
there— we’ve fetched up, ah, hard aground
north of, ah, Goose Island off Bligh Reef.
And, ah, evidently, ah, leaking some oil,
and, ah, we’re gonna be here for a while.
And, ah, if you want, ah, so you’re notified.
Over.
[end sound clip]
>>Lawrence Lessig: And ah, if you want, as,
so you're notified.
Over.
Now, as many of you are thinking, there might
be a little bit of a question about whether
Captain Joseph Hazelwood was intoxicated at
the time this accident occurred.
He denied it.
He said he only had four vodkas before he
got on the ship.
But his blood level alcohol indicated he must
have been at least six times over the legal
limit when he climbed on board that ship.
But he fought it.
His lawyers fought it hard.
There was some ambiguity in the evidence and
he was not convicted.
So, let's say there was doubt about whether
Hazelwood was drunk when he was captaining
a supertanker.
What there was no doubt about was that he
had a problem with alcohol.
His mother testified.
She had known he had a problem with alcohol.
In 1985, four years before the accident, Exxon
had treated him for his problem with alcohol.
After the accident, Exxon's President said
he "thought he had mastered the problem."
But in 1986, he had his driver's license revoked
for a DUI.
In 1988, he had his driver's license revoked
At the time he was captaining a supertanker,
he was not allowed to drive a VW Beetle.
[laughter]
OK.
But forget Hazelwood.
Instead, I want you to think about those around
Captain Hazelwood, these other officers.
People who could have picked up a phone while
a drunk was driving a supertanker.
I want you to think about the people who did
nothing because all but one of those officers
did nothing.
What do we think about them?
Now, I ask this question because as I think
about the problem this nation faces increasingly,
I believe we are they.
This nation faces critical problems requiring
serious attention, but we don't have institutions
capable of giving them this attention.
They are distracted, unable to focus.
And who is to blame for that?
Who is responsible?
I think it's too easy to point to the Blagojeviches
and hold them responsible, to point to the
evil people and hold them responsible.
It's not the evil people.
It’s the good people.
It's the decent people.
It's the people who could've picked up a phone.
It's us.
It's we, the most privileged.
Because the most outrageous part here is that
these corruptions, of course, were primed
by the most privileged, but they were permitted
by the passivity of the most privileged as
well--permitted by us.
When Ben Franklin was carried from the Constitutional
Convention in the summer of 1787, a woman
stopped him on the street and said, "Mr. Franklin,
what have you wrought?"
Franklin replied, "A republic, ma'am, if you
can keep it."
A republic.
A representative democracy.
A democracy dependent upon the people alone.
We have lost that republic and all of us have
to work to get it back.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
I'm happy to take questions.
I'm a law professor, so I could call on people
if you don't ask questions.
[laughter]
Yes, sir.
>>MALE #1: Do you have any opinions on electoral
reform?
I can't vote for the party I want 'cause if
I vote for anybody other than Republicans
or Democrats, my vote is wasted.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yeah.
I think that there's a whole list of other
reforms that we also need to think about with
democracy.
The way we gerrymander districts, the way
we have winner-take-all seats.
All of these things I think are critically
important, too.
I'm trying to think about the sequence of
problems.
And I think the sequence of problems is, this
is the problem we need to solve first to create
an atmosphere, an opportunity, to begin to
address the other problems.
So, I'm happy to sign up with you on that
once we fix the problem I'm talking about
here first.
Yeah.
>>MALE #2: Hi.
Two quick questions.
The first is, what's the name of the Senator
that came up with the little bastards that
are greedy in the greedy bastards quote?
>>Lawrence Lessig: He would not go on the
record with him name, [audience chuckles]
so the Huffington Post piece says it's an
anonymous Senator who said this.
>>MALE #2: OK.
Secondly, about the Constitution Convention,
using say, legislatures.
How are the state representatives gonna be
different from the national representatives?
'Cause aren't they just as greedy and looking
to climb the ladder of political opportunity?
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yeah, so state legislatures
just passed resolutions calling on the Convention.
And the question is, how do you populate the
Convention?
And here's the really insane, totally completely
insane idea, that I have for the Convention.
I think the Convention should be populated
by a random selection, random proportional
selection, of citizens.
Now, people think that's crazy.
And I agree.
You're not gonna argue anybody into insanity.
I think what you've gotta do is to show them,
like let's run 30 or 40 or 50 of these mock
Constitutional Conventions where we have deliberative
polls where we randomly select a representative
mix of people from a jurisdiction and we give
them the information they need.
And we have them work through the issue and
see what they come up with.
California has a good example of this.
The California Forward Project ran a deliberative
project, deliberative poll, around the question
of what California should do.
And the product of that is extraordinarily
impressive--much better than anything the
professionals did.
And I think that signals the core insight,
which is politics is one of these rare sports
where the amateurs are actually better than
the professional.
Because the professional is good at figuring
out how to benefit the special interests that
the professional depends upon.
And the amateur, like a jury, can be summoned
into a state where they're not thinking so
much about the special interest.
So, I think the only way a Convention makes
sense is if we can avoid it being captured
in exactly the same way government has been
captured.
And I think the only way to that is to have
this randomly selected body be the Convention.
>>MALE #3: First of all, thank you so much
for being here and for devoting so much time
to this very important issue.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Thank you.
>>MALE #3: My question is, given the election
of Obama in 2008, and then the following three
years, how much of the overwhelming Democratic
majorities and the election Obama have helped
the momentum of this campaign finance reform
campaign?
In that, I think there's a lot of people who
sort of generally understand the Republicans
were bought, but I think when the nation was
rallied around this feeling in 2008, and then
the disappointment that's come out of it,
I just--.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yeah.
You and I share that view precisely.
The book is--.
Obama was a friend.
He was a colleague of mine in Chicago.
I campaigned for him.
I worked hard for him.
I talked to a lot of people in here when he
first was on the trail about how he'd be so
great for what we cared about.
But the only reason I think he was credible
as a candidate over Hilary Clinton, was that
he, unlike Hilary Clinton, said, "This system
is the problem.
We have to take up the fight to change the
way Washington works.
And if we don't, our children are gonna be
facing the same problems we faced.
And our children's children will be facing
the same problems they face."
So, he made it--.
He said twice at least, I have recorded in
the campaign, "This is the reason I am running.
To change the system."
And then he got elected and he opened up the
Clinton playbook.
And he ran his Administration according to
the way Hilary Clinton would've run her Administration.
And I think maybe Clinton would have done
a better job.
I don't know.
But if Clinton had done exactly what Barack
Obama did, I think we should say, "Great.
You did what would come from that kind of
Administration.
But you promised, Barack Obama, a different
Administration."
I feel it's a betrayal from what we thought
we were getting.
It makes it really hard for any of us to believe
that reform is gonna come from the top or
from any insider.
So, I think that this is why it becomes critical
to think about these outside traditional politics
solutions, which is unfortunately, I think,
the only path we've got right now.
He doesn't stand credible on this issue.
The one person who is credible on this issue
is--.
I will vote for Obama over any Republican
except one.
The Republican you've not heard of.
His name is Buddy Roemer.
Now, it's funny you haven't heard of him.
I mean, he was a governor.
He was a four-term Congressman.
He ran a bank for 20 years without taking
government bailouts and successfully created
this community bank.
But he has made a pledge in his campaign for
the Republican nomination for President where
he will take no more than a hundred dollars
from anybody.
He will commit to no PAC money, full disclosure,
because he wants to as his slogan, "It's free
to lead."
But because he takes no more than a hundred
dollars, everybody says, "Well, you can't
possibly win so, we're not even gonna pay
attention to you."
So, he hasn't even had a chance to make this
case in the debate.
But if Buddy Roemer were the candidate in
the Republican side, that would be a game-changer.
If it were a Republican making this argument,
then it would be much easier to imagine this
argument actually having play.
>>MALE #3: Thank you.
>>MALE #4: Thank you for coming to talk to
us today.
I have a question about--.
I think we all can understand that there's
obviously a role that Congress has in perpetuating
this system.
And there's a role that we all have in our
lack of action in perpetuating this system.
But I think one thing, you didn't get a chance
to talk about and I don't know if you talk
about it in your book--I look forward to reading
it--is the role of the Supreme Court and notably
one of your own bosses.
And how you talk about the people want to
be more involved, but at this point, the Supreme
Court has defined "person" to be an incredibly
broad system and how we can move away from
treating corporations as people without their
movement and how we can actually affect meaningful
change without movement on the Supreme Court.
And a Supreme Court that seems very unlikely
to move on that particular issue.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yeah.
So, the particular version of public funding
that I advance is completely immune from Supreme
Court invalidation.
Nothing in the Supreme Court, even this Supreme
Court's doctrine, would draw this type of
public funding into the out.
But it leaves the problem of independent expenditures,
both of individuals, George Soros or the Koch
Brothers, as well as corporations, which now
have unlimited amounts to spend.
And it took a comedian to teach the Supreme
Court that, in fact, they didn't have to be
disclosed if they all could be secret because
you could channel them through a C4 that would
itself be identified, but the contributors
to the C4 not.
OK.
So, we have to address the problem of independent
expenditures.
Now, my view is the law should not ban anybody
from saying anything.
I think corporations should have a right to
participate.
But they shouldn't be able to dominate the
political process so that we have not just
shape-shifting to appeal to the funders, but
we have shape-shifting to appeal to the independent
expenditure guys and therefore, the same kind
of dependency that corrupts the system.
So, the only way to get there without imagining
a Supreme Court reversing itself is to give
Congress the power to limit, but not to ban,
independent expenditures.
And if you're gonna change the Constitution
from that standpoint, I say let's have an
amendment that has three components.
Number one, public elections must be publicly
funded.
Number two, contributions to candidates should
be capped.
I'd say at a hundred dollars--equivalent of
a hundred dollars.
Number three, Congress has to have the power
to limit, but not to ban, independent expenditures
of both corporations and people.
It just has to have the capacity to create
a time for election that's not just about
the money.
But getting to the place that we can have
the chance to have that amendment passed,
is the hard thing because again, I looked
it up, there's zero chance Congress is gonna
propose such an amendment.
And so, if Congress is not gonna propose the
amendment, what's the path to get it at least
on the table for states to adopt?
>>MALE #4: Thank you very much.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yup.
>>FEMALE #1: Hi.
I'm wondering about your perspective on venture
philanthropy and the role of money outside
the congressional system.
Is it a pure good?
I'm thinking, for example, of education reform,
the Charter School movement, that sort of
thing.
Or, is there some danger there that money
is talking more than it ought to, even in
those worlds?
>>Lawrence Lessig: Yeah.
It's a great question.
I don't think you can say without reservations
that it's good.
Although, you can say it's really great that
it's out there, right?
There are foundations that are not disciplined
enough to insulate and protect the recipients
from developing the wrong kind of dependency
on the foundation.
So, it distorts them in a way that I think
is not productive.
And so, harmful.
But I think there are others that adopt a
very appropriate relationship to the targets
of their giving that allows them to maintain
their independence, but does support their
work.
So, I think in a case-by-case way, we gotta
make a decision about what's the appropriate
kind of relationship to be drawing in that
case.
>>FEMALE #1: Thank you.
>>MALE #5: So, we're out of time to take more
questions, but thanks again for coming.
>>Lawrence Lessig: Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
[applause]